[Music]
so jeff
uh-huh yeah i'm back at it all right
let's let's go there
are you old enough to remember when the
united states attempted
to convert to the metric system thank
god no that had to
because i'm so glad it worked out
so i joke about this because back then
and today
drug dealers have always been metric
right
just think about that they don't sell
cocaine in pounds that's in kilos that's
right
so that'll get you the same that that'll
get you
another measurement of time
one that einstein had hadn't explored
yet that's right you go
yes exactly so
i've heard people joke that if we had
put drug lords as head of the
metric commission in the united states
we all would have been metric within
months right wait are you that afternoon
after that afternoon we'd have been 100
metric and and high
what i'm trying to communicate is that
we're not as bad
as it may seem we are
much farther along than
we even admit to ourselves
in this conversion i just want to sort
of put it out there
okay and i'm going to tell you why
because i don't want you to feel bad
about this now i is a scientist we're
metric from the beginning
that's not even a thing engineers a
little later in the in the
in the listening but scientists we speak
internationally
we and that's the international system
that gets used okay right so in fact
it's called
system international the si system of
units
the meter the kilogram the second is in
there but everybody uses the second so
so you know the french came up with the
metric system did you know this
no wonder we don't use it
[Laughter]
when you get this editorial
so it got implemented in 1789 and what
was happening
then in france 1789.
yeah 89. in part inspired by what
happened in the united states
uh was that the best deal storming and
all that yeah
french revolution yeah right yeah so
part of that sort of overthrowing of all
previous order
that was the occasion if you're gonna do
it that's a good time to do it
right in addition to the rolling heads
you throw in the metric system
we need everywhere to figure out how
these heads
roll faster how is it that we get to
head to robhasa
we're gonna put the basket down let it
roll and we shall measure it in no way
i see the hair go from the guillotine
as it went down as
i smoke a cigarette and watch
[Laughter]
that's exactly how it happened
all right so they uh
so do you know the original definition
of a meter
no okay so somebody had to come up with
that right right i mean it's pretty
obvious a foot is somebody's foot
right in the met in the in the imperial
units but a meter
was 1 10 millionth
the distance from the north pole
to the equator on a path that went
through the paris observatory so that's
that's how it began
and that they became standardized then
they created an artifact
out of platinum and iridium an alloy of
those two and that there was an etch
mark on one end and on the other
and that was the length of the meter
that you can go
and reference it uh in france
uh so that you can then take a meter
home with you that was the correct line
so that's an example and they had an
object called the kilogram
and it's in a vault and there it is one
kg all right but point is it had a
beginning and all this metric beginning
was in 1789 i'm just saying okay
okay so uh so here we are in the united
states
and we we kind of have metric envy a
combination of metric envy
and and imperial pride
all right we're using fahrenheit and
inches and meters and cups and
tablespoons and we're damn proud of it
but at the end of the day i think it's
like yeah
maybe we kind of want a little bit of
metric in our lives so i just want to
impress upon you we already do are you
ready
i am ready and and by the way i'm saying
we have been
inching towards the metric system for
decades
i see what you did there
okay so first of all
we had metric money
from the start okay this sounds like
bitcoin i'm not sure if i'm in
how many pennies in a dime how many
dimes in a dollar
yeah all right base 10 yeah it's base 10
all the way at the time england was
using pounds and shillings and pence and
that
and i still don't know how that system
worked
to this day and i'm a full-grown adult
who've thought about it
okay so so first we had metric money
put that in the bank okay all right what
else do we have
oh our photography
has largely been metric from the
beginning
all right there's 35 millimeter film
right you didn't measure that in inches
all right you had a 50 millimeter lens
all lenses are
measured all the lenses are measured in
now there was some film formats there
were inches there was four by five
right and eight by ten those are the
larger formats but most of all the
others
was metric and the lenses were metric
you go to the movie 70 millimeter wide
you know
2001 a space odyssey 1968 in
70 millimeters no one was freaking out
that you saw
mm next to the 70. right okay okay
so photography was in all right
what else was in oh our medicine
has been metric like practically
forever all right so you have you know
it's one cc
of some drug or one it's what is a cc
it's a cubic centimeter
that's what a cc is no doctor gives you
a shot of an
ounce
[Laughter]
i need an ounce of penicillin stat
doctor you're going to kill him
he's dead jim he's already dead he's
already dead
so so medical dosing
has been metric like forever okay
uh add to that our nutrition labels
those were metric from the beginning
how many grams of fat oh that's how many
milligrams okay just look on any
nutritional label it's all metric and
it's been that way and no one is
freaking out
by looking at this okay
how many grams this how many grams that
so what do we have in the bank now we
got we got metric money
metric medicine metric photography
metric um
nutrition labels what else oh
we've got metric bottles of soft drink
you've never in your life purchased a
quart of pepsi
i have a leader no you haven't it's a
liter
okay a liter slightly more than a quart
but close enough
you know for most purposes but so one
liter two liter three liter bottles of
pepsi
that's right okay so
our larger volumes non-dairy
larger bottles have been metric for a
long time
okay for decades it's funny because
everything you're mentioning right now
are all
global commodities yes soda is global
photography is global good point we're
not shipping milk
yeah that's correct right that's correct
yeah uh
pharmaceuticals are global it's all
global stuff that you're talking okay
well
well let me keep going all right okay
i'm not done yet
one of the last things i thought would
have changed
okay was the
volume displacement of the pistons in an
engine
okay i drove a car
that was a 400 cubic inch v8 engine
that's right nobody measures it in cubic
inches anymore not anymore
it's in liters that's how you run 1
liter 2 and that leader if you ever
wondered is not the volume of any liquid
in it
is the volume of the cylinders in the
in the engine block itself 4.0 liter
yeah that's right it's a much of how
much sort of uh movement
and power you're getting out of the
engine it's one of
several measures you can invoke so
that's metric
okay okay and uh shall i keep going
about
those are important things i think okay
now we still have fahrenheit yes
and we still have sort of miles and
and our cooking is not really metric
so it's like three holdouts cooking
distance cooking measurements distance
temperature and baking okay right so
when people say
america you got to join us with the rest
of the world with the metric system we
kind of
already have a b i don't
i'm i don't feel even as a scientist
speaking i don't feel some great urge to
give up
fahrenheit and feet in inches i'll tell
you why
when you visit another country um
[Music]
part of what it is to sort of blend in
and to fit in and to learn is to learn
what their customs are
in america jack we use fahrenheit and
just deal with it
okay i mean you know i'm going over to
my neighbors and trying to borrow 236
milliliters of sugar
i'm new to the neighborhood do you have
236 milliliters of sugar
slammed into her back
anyway i think we come a long way so
we're inching and maybe dairy comes next
i don't know
um i kind of like the fact that you know
eggs come in a dozen a dozen is a nice
historical baker's
quantity i like that and so i'm i'm
cool with that let me remind you that
we had a mission to mars where the
engineers were using
the imperial system and the scientists
were using the metric system
and there's a point where two
calculations had to come together
and their their units were not converted
to match
and so the propulsion that was put into
play
to go into orbit around mars was the
wrong thrust and it basically overshot
mars completely and so we lost
you know 100 million dollar spacecraft
because of not because two systems
didn't match it's not because we weren't
on metric
it's that because the system was not
turned into a common
um a common set of measures that that's
why
had that been done we wouldn't have had
the problem even if the engineers
continued to use
a feet and inches wow
that that right well okay
that was egg on our face that was it
that looked bad especially for nasa
without a doubt yeah yeah it's like
missed it by that much
almost it doesn't count yeah if you're
trying to reach a planet
no it doesn't count damn
oh yeah that's awful yeah all right so i
just wanted to say
we're inching towards the metric system
and we're there in ways you probably
hadn't thought about
and so that's my little bit of that
there it is once again
chuck you've heard it here and i'm neil
degrasse tyson as always
keep looking up
[Music]